[Aplausos]
se todas as criações de oito anos ouvirem
aprender a meditar não é eliminar
a violência do mundo que se soma hoje a
que força tem essa frase dalai lama
muitos adultos têm isso hoje yoga e
meditação que para adultos e sim
nós posamos o yoga se importa com o
a reprodução de hoje será aquela como o falo dalai
lama conseguimos transformar o mundo
essa amizade ou propósito de vida ou
yoga significa união união com o
natureza e animais com tudo
seres vivos mistificam a palavra eu
carga com seis yoga yoga não é um
religião
josé não precisa faltar usado para
mal aprender sânscrito e cantar cobertores
praticar yoga yoga é muito mais
simples é que tudo o que é necessário
conectar vereador ccoo se conectar com o
cidade respira estava aprendendo tudo
que você todas as ferramentas que você tem
iate para aliviar seu estresse libras um
vida mais tranquila e estar alinhado com
seu propósito
Wilson que as escolas nos finais de semana
pegue dois patifes um dedo eles marcam
acredito que cinco anos de arte aqui e
cols los fíos tv quais as medidas
há muitos três carros agora com 10
alvos
ele está lembrando amanhã o estande para
botão fase scola em todas as disciplinas
para casa
atividades extracurriculares de
lista de pneus para casa de banho vai para
dorme
mato já tem vida toda robotizada
aguentar muitos 3 a 2 com isso algum estefan
não está na minha hora de respirar
hoje para a frança uau que poder incrível
custos fixos facer yoga ou desde
se inscreveu para apoio aos pais
é muito mais divertido muito mais brincalhão
é muito mais dinâmico não é não chega
para pais, usamos dois cartões
apartamentos com deus
a prole identifica os animais e
lá eles começam a enfrentar posturas de visões
começar a fazer histórias que vão para
o caramanchão da montanha nua e olhar para fora
bilhetes de iate voam isso e yoga
para nutrir os grandes pilares do yoga
são respiração forçada ou equilíbrio
e relaxar a respiração de um
gama de hardware que todos nós temos e
grátis até agora não precisamos
aprender a usar a respiração nos ajuda
muito para se acalmar ou não suas três saídas
com seus efeitos estressantes e respirar
software calmante po mais adultos
vamos tornar o Paraná mais complicado do que
Moore trusts saltamos de um
xeito como animais por exemplo como
eu respiro coello coello respira mas ninguém
É muito rápido e é tudo emprestado
quando respiramos com o pescoço ou não é
armadura vai muito rápido ou nos aumenta
tudo está perturbado novamente, mas e
respiramos milho calmamente como um
barulho de elefante nós inspiramos nós elevamos o
tromba de elefante e expira musgo e
entremeado que se pratica muitos simples
para todos os filhotes aprender a
relacionado ao forza nos ajuda a fazer
Foco de Natal, caso contrário seremos forçados a
educação chega ao fim ou quem o
grupo e e aumenta muito é que o foco é
auto-estima todas as posturas que temos
vamos passar equilíbrio como é aqui da
árvores nos dão muita auto-estima começou
em um eu ganho mais quando fico fica
ainda e ver isso comigo mesmo
isso me superando que me dá muito
auto-estima para que fique muito claro para
todo mundo eu
desafio no final enviou esta mensagem para
todos os pais e todos os professores
e todos os diretores de escola que
estão subindo agora para abrir e de
justificar ou yoga que não religião e
acima de tudo não tenho petista nem bases
eles perseveraram os jogos olímpicos não
medalha de ouro do maior eu não existe
eu não tenho idéia hoje ou ganso como você
mesmo em todos oferecidos essas vigias
vamos mostrar para 26 como fazemos um
onda de ioga para pais para você
entender mais a prática como funciona ou
convide os pequenos iogues médios
pietro e agora natasha natalia por favor
para ir até a caixa
o sapato aqui vamos tratar o amor
abraços cruzados para nos inspirar o o
[Música]
ou
santi chanti chanti
e ari e o
iniciamos juntos duas fábricas do
pés para brindar corridas porque agora vamos
lançar cédulas
todo mundo vai jogar outro lado
balas para outro dia por bilhete abre para
sas Faith Hill e fotos e envelopes muito chiques
porque o próximo teste falhou juntos
plantas hospes veste calcañar para poder
ir para o bilhete reverso
[Música]
e votar hoje para a planta, em seguida, subir 4 e um
casal top dent ponte e para a maioria
ousando mais doloroso sobre eles
obter gostos completos ótimos
lanças
bogotá
nós estávamos indo para o tigre enquanto eu respiro figura
cabeça erguida
inspirou aquela cabeça nas margens
trabalho da vida chegou a tigre el tigrito
circo criou uma cadela para trailers e
levante a mão para a frente e olhe para
equilíbrio e troca de ama
jz o cala e fala mais pra frente
para frente a frente somente pai brasil
o azul surpreso sobe mais uma vez
a pessoa falsifica sinais aumenta após
foram cancelados
foto v barco juntos pescar juntos bausch
apenas acima, pois temos muitos barcos
navio pirata de pescador kajaki marcado o
oh oh oh para navios transatlânticos cuja
último fundo vermelho titânico
votem juntos p
e vamos plantar muraco a mente nasce
hit magic mind xv eu tampa e o que
precisamente por que fazer um show e três
suba
[Música]
a ascensão é flor e acima de tudo
árvores mesmo agora que flores tão
maravilhoso eu acho o cachorro
[Música]
nenhum dos eventos aqui a ala oeste por
villa lujã fernández e respirar o
não
tudo
[Música]
cobain ou mais
nunca disse e votando em mim para frase
comecei a registrar e adoro
se todas as criações de oito anos ouvirem
aprender a meditar para aprender, mas
yoga para a consciência do corpo ou poder
a respiração
poderíamos eliminar a violência deste
numeração mundial vamos a brigada mais
lindo
[Aplausos]